[Música]
el mundo superó el umbral de las 3
millones de personas fallecidas por el
virus kobe 19 según la universidad johns
hopkins la organización mundial de la
salud advirtió que el planeta estaba a
punto de alcanzar el mayor pico de casos
desde el inicio de la pandemia y américa
del sur enfrenta la tercera ola que
lleva acompañada de nuevas restricciones
el jefe de la junta militar de mianmar
asistirá a la cumbre de la asociación de
naciones del sudeste asiático asean es
su primer viaje desde el golpe de estado
del primero de febrero entretanto siguen
las protestas en el país y los birmanos
o pro democracias celebran la formación
de un gobierno paralelo con
parlamentarios derrocados
y la familia real británica despide al
duque de edimburgo la ceremonia
comenzará con un homenaje militar y será
en el castillo de windsor con apenas 30
personas entre familiares y allegados
por la pandemia
el primer ministro boris johnson no
asistirá el consorte de la reina isabel
segunda falleció el 9 de abril a los 99
años tenemos reporte desde londres
una feliz mañana de sábado mi nombre es
ángela gómez y aquí comienza el
informativo de france 24 iniciamos con
la cifra más reciente de la pandemia de
kobe 19 el mundo superó 3 millones de
fallecimientos y 140 millones de
contagios los recuperados de la
enfermedad son casi 80 millones cuando
el planeta vive la tercera ola con
variantes más contagiosas
precisamente la organización mundial de
la salud advirtió que la pandemia está a
punto de alcanzar el mayor pico de
contagios desde su inicio en américa
latina' se hace evidente el incremento
de los nuevos casos argentina brasil
colombia y ecuador siguen marcando
récords con las unidades de cuidados
intensivos saturadas marina sardenya
amplia
américa latina' en alerta por la nueva
ola de la pandemia de kobe 19 argentina
rompió un nuevo récord de casos diarios
con casi 30.000 positivos el vertiginoso
aumento de los contagios pese a las
críticas restricciones impuestas en el
área metropolitana de buenos aires ha
puesto al límite a las unidades de
cuidados intensivos de la capital
lamentablemente creo que vamos a empezar
a ver lo que hemos visto en ecuador'
en brasil perú gente
en los pasillos con oxígeno no
recibiendo
tal vez el mejor tratamiento
espero que no pero espero equivocarme en
brásil los cementerios están desbordados
con más de 368 mil decesos desde el
inicio de la pandemia los hospitales
brasileños carecen de medicinas y las
sucias están copadas en su mayoría por
pacientes jóvenes además la variante
brasileña del patógeno sigue haciendo
estragos por lo que las autoridades
sanitarias pidieron a las mujeres que
pospongan el embarazo
la experiencia clínica de los
especialistas muestra que esta nueva
variante actúa de forma más agresiva en
las mujeres embarazadas
el viernes colombia confirmó la
circulación de la variante británica en
el turístico departamento del eje
cafetero las autoridades colombianas
impusieron un estricto confinamiento a
cerca de 12 millones de personas en las
regiones más golpeadas por la enfermedad
alertadas por la alta ocupación de las
uci sin embargo muchos comerciantes se
oponen al entierro y reclaman ayuda
hasta alistado la enfermedad muy
terrible eso no lo negamos yo la viví el
año pasado estuve 15 días en cama a
causa el coronavirus pero le digo que es
más fuerte que esa enfermedad la crisis
económica porque con hambre
no se vive ecuador y paraguay también se
encuentran en una situación crítica con
los hospitales saturados y el
agotamiento de los profesionales de la
salud
cambió de tema este viernes raúl castro
renunció al liderazgo del partido
comunista cubano por primera vez en más
de 60 años el poderoso y único partido
de la isla será comandado por alguien
que no es de la familia el anuncio se
dio durante la apertura del octavo
congreso del partido e incluyó los
relevos de otros veteranos que
pertenecen a la cúpula de dirigentes
nacidos después de la revolución del 59
muchos cubanos están ansiosos por lo que
se avecina el fin de la era castro el ex
presidente raúl castro quien cumplirá 90
años en junio renunció a la jefatura del
partido comunista de cuba el rock a vis
se refiere
concluye mi tarea como primer secretario
del comité central del partido comunista
de cuba
con la satisfacción de haber cumplido y
la confianza en el futuro de la patria
con la meditada convicción de no aceptar
propuestas para mantenerme en los
hombros superiores de la organización
partidista en cuya actividad
continua revolucionario más el congreso
que se celebra cada cinco años es la
reunión en la que se elige a la
dirección del partido y se establecen
las directrices políticas que marcan el
rumbo de cuba en 2016 raúl castro dijo
que sería la última sesión dirigida por
la llamada generación histórica de
veteranos revolucionarios ahora por
primera vez en más de 60 años el partido
único de la isla no tendrá un miembro de
la familia castro al frente y será el
actual mandatario miguel díaz canel
designado por castro quien tomará el
relevo al frente del partido como hizo
con la presidencia en 2018 sería el
último en ocupar este cargo pero bueno
está el relevo el relevo que está
instruido está capacitado y creo que
nuestro país salga adelante con eso el
cambio en la dirección se produce cuando
cuba afronta su peor crisis económica en
décadas grabada por la pandemia y las
sanciones impuestas en los últimos días
de la administración trump muchos
cubanos esperan mejoras sociales con gas
tarazá con el congreso esto mejor en
donde este repito porque los presos está
muy alto
siguieron los salarios pero no sé si va
a lo mismo eso es por gusto porque en
definitiva no saltan sin embargo los
analistas apuntan a que la nueva
generación de jóvenes líderes hagan
cambios poco radicales en el modelo
político cubano
el expresidente peruano martín vizcarra
acusó este viernes al congreso de su
país de haber perdido legitimidad tras
la noticia de su inhabitant
inhabilitación para cualquier cargo
público por diez años
vizcarra gobernó entre 2018 y 2020 fue
destituido en noviembre por incapacidad
moral y este viernes fue sancionado por
haberse vacunado en secreto contra kobe
19 mientras aún estaba en su cargo
detalles con nuestro corresponsal en
lima francisco zacarías
el escándalo del vacuna gate le terminó
cobrando la factura al expresidente de
martín vizcarra la inhabilitación del
congreso de perú por 10 años de toda la
función pública le impide recibir las
credenciales de congresista
vizcarra según el conteo oficial fue
electo como el congresista más votado en
lima en las elecciones generales que se
realizaron este domingo en perú la
sanción del parlamento fue respaldada
con 86 votos de los legisladores quienes
consideran que martín vizcarra violó la
constitución y aprovechó su cargo como
presidente para vacunarse de forma
irregular con dosis de la vacuna contra
el cob y 19 el mayor agravante para los
legisladores radica en que usó el poder
para direccionar la vacunación
clandestina también para su esposa y su
hermano vizcarra tenía previsto ser
congresista en el período 2021 2026 y
luego postular a la presidencia del perú
la inhabilitación bloquea su futuro
político sin embargo el exgobernante
anuncia que apelará la sanción del
parlamento con un recurso de amparo ante
la justicia peruana y también señaló que
emprenderá acciones legales en
tribunales internacionales
el congreso de perú también
inhabilitó a las exministras pilar ct y
elizabeth astete por ocho años y un año
respectivamente en mianmar continúa en
las manifestaciones después de más de
dos meses del golpe de estado pero este
viernes miles de birmanos celebraron la
creación de un gobierno paralelo
prodemocracia comandado por
parlamentarios de puestos por la junta
entre tanto el líder golpista confirmó
su asistencia a la cumbre más importante
de las naciones asiáticas en la asean
maría clara calle tiene los detalles
con pancartas que le dan la bienvenida
al autodenominado nuevo gobierno y
diciendo que esto marca la nueva era de
la revolución de la primavera así es
como decenas de manifestantes salieron a
las calles una vez más en mí al mar para
protestar en contra de la junta militar
y también para respaldar al llamado
gobierno de unidad nacional una idea que
crearon el pasado viernes políticos pro
democracia y parte de los parlamentarios
derrocados
la democracia federal puede mejorar el
sistema educativo los problemas sociales
las relaciones internacionales las
empresas como estudiantes estamos muy
contentos de ver la formación del
gobierno de unidad nacional
pero los líderes militares siguen firmes
de hecho el jefe de la junta birmana
ming aun line asistirá a la cumbre que
celebrará la asean que es la asociación
de las 10 naciones del sudeste asiático
la cita será en indonesia el próximo 24
de abril esta será la primera vez que
los militares que asumieron el poder por
la fuerza participarán en una reunión
internacional mientras el autodenominado
gobierno de unidad le pide a la asean
que rechace a la junta y que reconozca
al gobierno paralelo como el legítimo
otra de las noticias en mianmar es la
liberación de presos un portavoz del
departamento de prisiones confirmó que
indultaron a más de 23.000 reos como
parte de un perdón judicial por el año
nuevo budista que se celebra en el país
este sábado sin embargo se desconoce si
los insultados incluyen a algunos de los
más de 3.100 manifestantes prodemocracia
que han sido detenidos desde el golpe de
estado
y hoy la familia real del reino unido-
se despide del duque de edimburgo
fallecido el pasado 9 de abril a sus 99
años de edad el último adiós para el
consorte de la reina isabel segunda será
austero y pequeño debido a la pandemia
contrario al tradicional funeral de
estado la oficina de la reina sólo
incluyó 30 invitados cuidadosamente
elegidos entre familiares y allegados
incluso el primer ministro boris johnson
cedió su lugar a un miembro de la
familia los actos serán en el palacio de
windsor a las afueras de londres y su
cuerpo será enterrado en la cripta real
de la capilla de san jorge en londres
está nuestra corresponsable de luisa
pulido buen día para ustedes luisa y una
semana de homenajes se cierra hoy cuáles
son los detalles de este funeral
buenas tardes desde windsor este será un
funeral militar que reflejará la vida
del duque de edimburgo así como su amor
por el mar veremos hoy las insignias de
el duque personales su herencia griega y
danesa así como las medallas de su
carrera especialmente exitosa como
piloto de la armada real británica los
detalles de su funeral fueron
minuciosamente planeados por el propio
duque de edimburgo los himnos religiosos
y las lecturas que escucharemos en las
próximas horas fueron elegidas por el
mismo así como el carro que transportar
a su bata una gran ropa verde el cortejo
fúnebre arrancará a las dos y cuarenta
dentro del castillo de windsor que
ustedes pueden ver a mis espaldas la
parada militar tendrá unos 700
integrantes de las fuerzas militares
especialmente de la marina el cortejo
fúnebre tendrá un recorrido de 13
minutos cuando llegará a las escalinatas
de la casa de la capilla san jorge a que
ustedes pueden recordarla porque desde
ahí se realizó el matrimonio de príncipe
harry
y gana mar coll a las 3 de la tarde en
punto se realizará un minuto de silencio
en todo el país ya las 3 de la tarde un
minuto entonces arrancará este funeral
que tendrá 50 minutos de duración este
tiene también un significado muy
especial para el duque de edimburgo dado
que el funeral de su madre la princesa
alicia de battenberg también tuvo lugar
en esta capilla luisa como será el
primer funeral real en medio de una
pandemia y éste no será el lugar final
de descanso del duque
no definitivamente no el duque será
sepultado hoy en la bóveda real pero
posteriormente cuando la reina isabel
muera será sepultado junto a la reina y
otros integrantes de la familia real en
el memorial del rey jorge sexto la
familia el padre la rey el padre de la
reina la madre y la princesa margaret
definitivamente será un funeral muy
distinto como ustedes pueden ver a mis
espaldas aquí afuera del castillo de
windsor miles de personas se han
congregado pero no tantas como
generalmente serían en un evento normal
como mencionaste treinta personas son
los invitados la reina a sus cuatro
hijos sus ocho nietos y unos familiares
muy cercanos veremos una imagen muy
poderosa y al mismo tiempo triste
la reina isabel posiblemente sentada
sola y guardando la distancia social
como hace parte de las reglas aquí en
inglaterra en medio de esta pandemia
y ya para ir finalizando luisa le
pregunto sobre el legado del duque de
edimburgo se habla de más de 70 años de
servicio
si para todos los expertos y para la
gente del público el gran legado del
ducó de embargo ha sido ser el esposo de
la reina isabel se convirtió en padre en
el encargado de la educación de los
hijos de las labores más domésticas así
que para muchos su gran labor su gran
legado será por supuesto ser la roca de
la reina isabel durante 73 años de vida
matrimonial pero también el duque de
edimburgo tuvo un legado filantrópico
muy importante especialmente el duque el
premio duque de edimburgo que galardona
a los jóvenes para promover que sigan
teniendo desarrollo personal el duque de
edimburgo fue además jefe de más de 800
organizaciones de calidad en el reino
unido y en todo
pues lo que nos queda muy claro es que
definitivamente este es un evento
histórico cargado de simbolismo no tan
grande como lo estábamos esperando
lamentablemente para la familia real y
todo esto debido a la tercera y en
algunos países ya cuarta ola de kobe 19
gracias a usted por estar con nosotros y
a nuestros televidentes se pueden
continuar con nosotros también en
france24 punto com volvemos en minutos
con más buenos días
[Música]